the tech industry is crashing and
unfortunately there isn't a simple
answer as to why this has happened
before in the year 2000 during the
dot-com bubble but everything is
different this time around this downturn
is affecting nearly everyone tech stocks
are way down but so are traditional
retailers and even though bitcoin was
supposed to be protected against
inflation it's fallen over 50
but there are a few people who have
spent years preparing for this and i'm
not just talking about warren buffett
who's been focused on value stocks for
his entire career a small segment of the
market is doing just fine but the
question is why what do this year's high
performers see that we're all missing
and how did today's billionaires get
through previous financial downturns in
order to answer these questions we have
to analyze how we got here the last two
years have led to absolutely insane
growth for tech stocks the nasdaq more
than doubled venture capital investment
also doubled and the number of unicorn
startups worth more than a billion
dollars increased to over 1 000 tech was
already growing really quickly over the
last decade but 2020 and 2021
accelerated things to an absolute frenzy
there were four key drivers of this
recent growth first we saw a real
technological shift over the past decade
as cloud computing became ubiquitous and
software worked its way into every
aspect of personal and business life ten
years ago most companies use technology
in some capacity to manage their
businesses but recently it's become
clear that any company without a solid
technology strategy is dead in the water
this shift has led to hundreds of large
technology companies going public and
everyone was predicting that this trend
would continue but in previous business
cycles successful tech companies would
go public much earlier in their growth
that's changed and for the last few
years we've seen tech companies stay
private for much longer this trend has
led to more venture capital dollars
flowing into these late stage tech
startups without the public markets to
act as a check on company financials
valuations have soared these high
valuations were driven in part by low
interest rates since the us government
has kept interest rates so low investors
have gone hunting for new ways to earn
decent returns they can't just park a
billion dollars in bonds and make
reasonable money so they have to take
more risk on tech startups the low
interest rate environment created a glut
of capital that worked its way into tech
companies but now interest rates are
rising and every company is getting
repriced the last driver of the recent
tech surge was the covet effect when the
pandemic first hit venture capitalists
worried that there would be a severe
recession and startups would have
trouble raising more money sequoia
capital even published a memo saying
that this was a black swan event and
things were going to be incredibly
difficult for the foreseeable future but
then something unexpected happened the
us government stepped in with the
largest stimulus package in history and
ended the recession incredibly quickly
at the same time tech products like zoom
started to look indispensable so
investors started piling money into
anything that could be used remotely
travel companies still took a hit as did
anything related to in-person events but
overall things looked really good for
tech people were shopping online more
which led to massive growth for shopify
working out at home became extremely
popular so peloton took off and with
movie theaters closed indefinitely
netflix became the go-to place for
at-home entertainment there was a
problem though see after a few months of
adjustment everyone thought these
changes would be permanent the pandemic
had led to massive adoption of all these
tech products and there was no sign that
it would slow down but it did just look
at this graph of e-commerce shopping the
percentage of shopping activity that
happens online had been growing steadily
for decades from 2000 all the way to
2020 the graph is incredibly smooth but
then all of a sudden the pandemic hit
and e-commerce adoption spiked from 11
to nearly 16 but as things opened back
up people went back to their old habits
and started shopping in person more this
phenomenon is called reversion to the
mean and it's an incredibly powerful
force when looking at long-term trends
whenever there is a big market move
people rush to point to one single
reason to explain everything but that's
a trap the real story here is much more
complicated and it's better to think
about this as a sequence of events covet
hits in 2020 everyone thinks there will
be a massive recession but then the
government steps in with a huge stimulus
and low interest rates that puts dollars
in everyone's pockets consumers go out
and buy things and investors pour money
into companies but that creates a
problem see manufacturing capacity got
hit really hard during covid people were
sick and couldn't show up to factories
to make things so supply dropped and
what happens when supply drops while the
money supply increases demand that's
right inflation so now the government
has a new problem on their hands
inflation hurts everyone and you don't
need to look further than your local gas
station to see that prices are rising
and long-term inflation can create
reinforcing spirals that erode the value
of the us dollar the government doesn't
want that so they have to fight back the
answer is rising interest rates but this
hurts tech stocks the most stocks are
typically valued based on their future
cash flows and most tech companies
aren't generating a lot of cash flow
right now they're in growth mode working
hard to develop new products and scale
their businesses this is fine when
interest rates are low but as rates rise
they get hurt the most and that's what
we're seeing in the market currently the
nasdaq is down nearly 30 percent but we
need to dig in deeper to understand
what's really going on see not all
companies on the nasdaq are created
equal some are profitable and some
aren't and it's the unprofitable
companies that have been hit the hardest
at the end of last year unprofitable
tech companies were trading at 25 times
revenue but now they trade at just six
times revenue this collapse has already
hurt tech investors a ton but the real
question is what happens next in order
to answer that it's useful to look at
what happened during previous market
sell-offs see it's easy to watch a bunch
of high-flying tech companies fall in
value and immediately say oh this is
just like the dot-com bubble all over
again but that's not quite right in the
year 2000 basically any tech company
could go public on pure hype alone they
didn't need profits they didn't need
revenue and sometimes they didn't even
need a successful product that's what
happened with a company called mp3.com
that was one of the first attempts at
online music streaming in july of 1999
mp3.com went public at a valuation of 4
billion
the internet was extremely trendy and
online music streaming seemed like an
inevitability the only problem was that
the company was still extremely small by
all accounts at the peak of mp3.com the
company had less than 1 million daily
active users and was only making a few
million dollars in revenue per year now
let's compare that to spotify spotify
has over 422 million active users and
brings in nearly 10 billion in revenue
per year and yet while mp3.com was
valued at 4 billion
spotify is worth only 20 billion dollars
today so spotify has 400 times the
amount of users and over a thousand
times as much revenue but they're only
worth five times as much you can clearly
see how overvalued.com stocks were back
in 2000 so what's the point of this
comparison well it's meant to illustrate
that the tech companies we have today
are a lot more established than two
decades ago most of them make billions
of dollars and are actually used by
hundreds of millions of people music
streaming is clearly a valuable service
so even though the market may be
re-evaluating the appropriate price for
the company they clearly have built a
real business unlike what we saw during
the dot-com boom there's a good reason
why people are calling this the great
revaluation the current crop of tech
companies are real businesses they just
might be overvalued which is leading to
this massive sell-off now there's
another interesting lesson from the
dot-com crash we should dig into
amazon.com as the name implies the great
revaluation is all about how the market
values companies revenue multiples are a
big part of that for every dollar a
business generates in revenue how much
should that be worth to an investor
remember mp3.com was trading at more
than a thousand times revenue during the
dot-com bubble whereas spotify trades at
two times revenue today well jeff bezos
went through his own frothy period
during the dot-com boom at its peak
right before the turn of the millennium
amazon was trading at more than 55 times
revenue then the market tanked and even
though amazon has grown significantly
the revenue multiple has stayed constant
around three times revenue it's almost
as if investors went through a period of
price discovery where they really had no
idea how to value amazon but then all of
a sudden it clicked and the multiple has
been stable for the past two decades now
today we're seeing something very
similar happen with shopify the revenue
multiple has been all over the place in
2016 shopify was trading for around 10
times revenue then it spiked to over 60
times revenue during the pandemic and
now it's back down to around 10 times
revenue looking at the graph you can see
that investors still don't know how to
properly value shopify's stock and
that's a big part of the reason why
shopify's ceo toby lucky took to twitter
to ask if financial analysts are being
held accountable for their predictions
for another interesting historical
example let's look at the online pet
food industry back in 1999 there were
not one but four online pet food
companies that raised significant
funding petopia.com petsmart.com
pets.com and petstore.com all raised
tens of millions of dollars in 1999.
then in february of 2000 pets.com raised
82 million dollars more in an ipo by the
end of the year they had managed to
spend over a hundred million dollars
including two million dollars for a
super bowl ad and wind up bankrupt none
of those four companies generated
significant revenues but today we're
seeing something different chewy.com
seems to have figured out how to sell
pet food online because they sell a lot
of it nine billion dollars just in 2021
but even though their revenues have been
growing pretty steadily chewy's
valuation has been all over the place
during the pandemic they traded at
almost five times revenue now they're
back to just over one times revenue the
high expectations that covid would
permanently change consumer behavior are
coming crashing down to earth and with
it so are the valuations of these
companies a big part of why tech
companies could fetch sky-high
valuations historically has been the
fact that they capitalized on either
moore's law metcalfe's law or both
moore's law essentially says that
computers double in power every two
years while metcalfe's law says that
networks get exponentially more valuable
as they grow in the early days of
facebook they were kind of writing both
of these trends computers were getting
faster and cheaper so people were
spending more and more time online and
at the same time facebook was a network
that perfectly benefited from metcalf's
law every time someone signed up for
facebook the whole site got more
valuable because there was more content
on it but moore's law has been slowing
down for years now and many new tech
companies just simply don't have network
effects so these companies are grappling
with the painful realization that they
might not be able to justify as high of
revenue multiples as they have in the
past in 2008 the global financial crisis
caused a deep recession and a massive
market sell-off driven primarily by a
housing bubble and an intertwined
derivatives market the crisis didn't
affect tech all that much but it can
still be useful to look at as a guide
today just as the market was collapsing
sequoia capital released the now famous
r.i.p good times memo in the 56 slide
deck they cover dozens of different
macroeconomic indicators that help
explain what's going on things like
personal savings rates unemployment and
inflation were all key factors in
driving the last recession so the
question is how do we stack up today
well there's some good news and there's
some bad news first the good
unemployment is currently lower than it
was before the 2008 recession and
personal saving rates are also higher
before the housing crisis the average
u.s household was spending 13 of their
income servicing debt today that number
has fallen to 9 percent so overall more
people have jobs and households have
less debt good stuff the bad news is
that inflation is currently much higher
than it was going into the 2008
recession and that means that the
government will have fewer ways to
respond to the downturn the us
government also has way more debt than
it did back in 2008. actually it's twice
as much on a debt to gdp basis that
means that big bailout packages will
probably be harder to justify this time
around but there is some cause for
optimism as rough as the 2008 downturn
was innovation didn't slow down great
companies still get built regardless of
market conditions and that's what we see
time and time again in 2008 small
startups like airbnb square and stripe
all got going and made it through and in
the dot-com bubble google paypal and
amazon.com all found a way to persevere
even while the stock market was down 80
or more warren buffett is famous for
saying only when the tide goes out do
you discover who's been swimming naked
and i suspect we will see a lot of that
over the next few years startups that
haven't really found a way to deliver a
clear value to a customer will wash out
but the best companies will survive and
that's cause for optimism anyone who's
been in the startup world for more than
a few years can tell you how crazy 2020
and 2021 have been money has been flying
around like crazy and it was pretty
clear that it couldn't keep accelerating
forever but the question remains where
will the venture capital industry land
in a year or two after the dust settles
will it look like 2008 where vc
investing decreased by 30 percent or
will it look more like the dot-com
bubble where vc investing dropped by 87
well clearly a dot-com crash style
pullback would be terrible but if that
did happen the vc industry would only
reset to 2012 levels and that's actually
when i got my start in silicon valley it
wasn't easy to raise money for a startup
back in 2012 but it wasn't impossible my
first funding round was just seventeen
thousand dollars and i had to live in a
single bedroom in a rundown house that i
shared with my co-founder to stretch
that cash but i still got to work on
interesting problems and it ultimately
led me to where i am today even though
startups weren't able to raise millions
of dollars with nothing more than a
pitch deck back then it really wasn't
that bad i had enough money to pay rent
and it gave me all the time i needed to
learn to program some people who are
only interested in startups or
technology for the money will wash out
and go get other jobs but for the truly
dedicated builders nothing can stop them
so if you want an inspiring story of an
entrepreneur who stuck it out for
decades during good times and bad just
go watch my video on epic games next